Not suitable for children, or those who are easily disturbed.
Now why would that be?
Individuals suffering from anxiety or depression may not have a safe experience playing this game.
Ah!
By playing Doki Doki Literature Club, you agree that you are at least 13 years of age, and you consent to exposure of highly disturbing content.
Okay! *Awkward laughing* All right! I agree! :D
Why wouldn't I?!
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier, and welcome to Doki Doki Literature Club!
Now you guys have been asking me to play this game for a while now,
and I finally have an opportunity to get here and...
Uh...
Well apparently it's not everything that it seems to be. But me having played a lot of Yandere Simulator,
Can kind of see through the cutesy outside and, I probably know that this is gonna go very badly for me..
But I'm gonna play it! My name is Marki-Marki-poopy. It's-it's ya boi!
It's your boi Markipoopy! Come at- Nah. That's terrible name. Merkiflumly.
*Random noises as he comes up with bad names*
Makapa!
Ma- ni Mi - minkle MA MEh - min - Minkle min min mii
Moooorp. *giggling*
*More laughing*
It's your boy, Morp!
Hey, it's Morp. Hey guys, it's Morp. All right. Morp coming down the street.
Is that Morp-pasy?! Alright,
You know it is.
You know.
"I see an annoying girl running towards me from the distance, waving her arms in the air,
like she's totally oblivious to any attention she might draw to herself."
[Continues reading from the text box]
*Making fun of the noise Sayori is making*
Ah!
MORP
Oh you see like that like you were thinking about ignoring me
That's mean morph
That's mean. Well. If you if people stare at you for acting weird, then morp don't want to think we're a couple or something
fine fine, but you did wait for me after all I
Guess you don't have it in you to be mean even if you want to whatever you say Sayori whatever you say
We cross the street together and make our way to school as we draw near the streets become increasingly
Speckled with other students making their daily commute. By the way Morp
Have you decided on a club to join yet? A club, Morp don't join no Club
Morp told you already morp not interested in joining any clubs
Morp haven't been looking either
No, that's not true. You told me you would join a club this year
Did Morp?
I'm sure it's possible that Morp did in one of our many conversations were Morp dismissively go along with whatever she's going on about
Sayori likes to worry a little too much about Morp when Morp perfectly content
Just getting by on the average while spending Morp's free time on games and anime. I mean Morp like do nothing else
Uh-huh I was talking about how I'm worried about you won't learn how to socialize or have any skills before college
Your happiness is really important to me
You know and I know you're happy now
But I died the thought of you becoming a NEET in a few years because you're not used to the real world
You trust me, right
Don't worry. Don't make me keep worrying about you alright alright
Morp will look at a few clubs if it makes you happy no promises though Morp don't make promises
Will you at least promise me that you'll try a little?
Yeah, Morp guess Morp will promise you that
Yay! Why do I- Why do Morp let myself get lectured by such a carefree girl?
Maybe because she's cute more than that Morp is surprised Morp let myself- Morpself relent to her
Morp guess seeing her worry so much about me makes Morp want to ease her mind at least a little bit
Even if she does exaggerate everything inside of her mahead
mahead
The school days as ordinary as ever and it's over before Morp know it
After Morp pack up the Morp things Morp stares blankly at the wall looking for an ounce of motivation
Clubs
Sayori wants me to check out some clubs. I guess I have no choice. I'm gonna stop with the Morp thing cause it's
It's 1) hard to keep up with them, 2) really really annoying.
I have no choice, but to start with the anime club.
Hello~~. Oh
Sayori
Sayori must have come into the classroom while I was spacing out
I look around and realize that I'm the only one left in the classroom
I thought I'd catch you coming out of the classroom
But I saw you just sitting here and spacing out so I came in
Honestly you're even worse than me sometimes. I'm impressed
You don't need to wait up for me if it's gonna make you stay late for your own Club well
I thought you might need some encouragement, so I thought you know
Know what?
Well that you could come to my club
Sayori, that's the stupidest idea I've ever heard of there's no way I'm going to your club.
OH meenie
Sayori is vice president of the literature Club not that I was ever aware that she had any interest in literature in fact
I'm 99% sure she only did it because she thought it would be fun to help start a new club
Since she was the first one to show interest after the one who proposed a club
She inherited the title vice president
That said my interest in literature is guaranteed to be even less yeah
I'm going to the anime club Morp like anime More think anime the future of entertainment
C'mon, please?
Why do you care so much anyway?
Well, I kind of told the club yesterday that I would bring a new member and
Natsuki made cupcakes and everything
Don't make promises you can't keep. Morp can't keep picking up after you
I can't tell if Sayori is really that much of an airhead or if she's so cunning as to have planned all this out
I let out a long sigh
Fine Morp'll stop by for a cupcake, but that's it! Morp not gonna grab more more.
Yes, let's go
Something tells me this literature club ain't gonna be too good for my health
and thus today marks the day I sold my soul for a cupcake
I dejectedly follow Sayori across the school in upstairs a section of the school
I rarely visit being generally used for third-year classes and activities
Sayori, full of energy, swings open the classroom door
Everyone~~!
The new member is here!
I told you don't call me new member. My name is Morp
Yeah, I glanced around the room
Girl one Welcome to literature club. It's a pleasure meeting you.
You got purple hair
You're probably evil...
Sayori always says nice things about you
Seriously, you brought a boy.
You've got pink hair. You're even more evil than her
That's just my guess
Way to kill the atmosphere.
Oh Morp. What a nice surprise
You're gonna die first
I can tell this evil, evil-er,  gonna die. That's how it works.
Let's see. Welcome to the club
All words escape me in this situation
This club...
Is full of incredibly cute girls
Works out perfectly for me! Morp like cute girls.
What are you looking at if you want to say something say it
Sorry?
Natsuki
The girl with the sour attitude, who's name is apparently Natsuki, is one
I don't recognize her small figure makes you me think she's probably a first-year
She is also the one who made cupcakes according to Sayori
You can just ignore when she gets moody.
Sayori says that quietly in my ear then turns back towards the other girls
Anyway! This is Natsuki always full of energy and is Yuri the smartest in the club
Don't say things like that
I'm not smart at all
I'm incredibly dumb, come on now
Yuri, who appears comparably more mature and timid,
seems to have a hard time keeping up with people like Sayori and Natsuki.
Huh, well It's nice to meet both of you.
and it sounds like you already know Monica. Is that right that right?
That's right!
Monika here, it's great to see you again more
Monika- that's a weird pose to strike after that.
Why is your skirt all flowing upward-ly?
Hmm something seems magically bouncy about you.
We do know each other, well
We rarely talk
But we were in the same class last year
Monika was probably the most popular girl in class.
Smart, beautiful, athletic
There's something evil about her. It's almost like she sold her soul for all these wonderful things
Basically completely out of my league
So having her smile at me so genuinely feels a little...
*Monkey noises*
You too, Monika, you too... you too
Come sit down Morp. We made room for you at the table so you can sit next to me or Monica
I'll get the cupcakes.
Is gonna be a choice? Do I have to choose? I'm gonna ju-
I'm gonna save real quick here.
There we go
Hey. I made them. I'll get them.
Sorry. I get a little too excited
Then how about I make some tea as well.
I'm the mature and smart one apparently
The girls have a few desks arranged to form table.
As Sayori mentioned,
It's been widened said that there's one space next to Monika and one space next to Sayori
*Creepy laughter*
I get to choose. I get to ch- I get to choose
Natsuki and Yuri walk over to the corner of the room
where Natsuki grabs the wrap tray and Yuri opens the closet
Still feeling awkward. I take-
Oh oh come on come on Morp's better than that oh
Come on
Natsuki proudly marches back to the table tray in hand
Okay, are you ready? No? I'm not. okay tah-dah
Okay, Oh
Natsuki lifts the foil off the tray to reveal a dozen white fluffy cupcakes decorated to look like little cat
I like how I like how Sayori's reaction came before the actual reveal like it was just a plate with foil over and she's
Just like wow
Wow wow and then lift it off, and there's the actual cakes
And it doesn't matter the whiskers are drawn with icing and little pieces of chocolate were used to make the ears so
Cute I had no idea you were so good at baking Natsuki. Oh
Well, you know I don't know just hurry and take one Ciara grabs one first then Monica
I follow it's delicious. I haven't even eaten it yet, but it's good
Sayori talks with her mouth full and has already managed to get icing on her face
What a klutz I turned the cupcake around in my fingers looking for the best angle to take a bite
I bite the head right off of that cat
Natsuki is quiet
I can't help but notice her sneaking glances in my direction is she waiting for me to take a bite
I finally bite down. Oh the icing is sweet and full of flavor. I wonder if she made it herself
It's really good, Morp like this
*Fake eating sounds*
Morp like icing, is this sugar?
Good stuff. Thank you Natsuki.
W-Why are you thanking me? It's not like I...
Is that a is that a tsun-dere character?
Okay, haven't I heard this somewhere before...
...made them for you or anything no
I thought you technically did, Sayori said-
boo well maybe
It's not like I'm in love with you or anything
Oh god damn it whatever.
But not for you. You know, you dummy.
You know I don't know oh god. I'm so cute all right all right, okay?
I give up on Natsuki's weird logic and dismiss the tsundere conversation
or as I call it the ta soon dare a conversation
Yuri returns to the table carrying a tea said she carefully
Places the tea cup in front of each of us before sending down the tea pot next to the cupcake tray
You keep a whole tea set in this classroom. You're so sophisticated
*Creepy whisper* I like that. I like that alot
Don't worry the teachers gave us permission after all doesn't a hot cup of tea help you enjoy a good book
Yes, I like reading. I like reading a lot. I really do Andy weir just came out with a new book
He *Flubbed word attempt* the guy that made the Martian. Have you read that one?
I haven't read it yet, but it seemed pretty good
I don't know maybe
Don't let yourself get intimidated
Yuri's just trying to impress you
I can see that and it's working on Morp. Morp very impressed. All right.
Uh, that's not uh
insulted Yuri looks away
I mean that you know I believe
You I believe you I believe you're trying to impress me
I believe that well tea and reading might not be a pastime for me, but at least I enjoy tea
I'm glad I'm glad too
Okay, Yuri faintly smiles to herself in relief
Morp faintly smiles to himself in arousal *Chuckling*
Monika raises an eyebrow then smiles at me.
So what made you consider literature club?
I didn't, Morp was forced here by Sayuki
I was afraid of this question
Something tells me I shouldn't tell Monika was practically- Oh Sayori, dragged here by Sayori
Well, I haven't joined any clubs yet, and Sayori seemed really happy here, so
That's okay. Don't be embarrassed
We'll make sure you feel right at home. Okay as president of the literature Club
it's my duty to make the club fun and exciting for everybody
Okay, when does the murder start cuz I heard there was murder
Der any murder here
Monika, I'm surprised. How come you decide to start your own Club?
You could probably be a board member for any of the major clubs
Weren't you the leader of the debate club last year?
Oh there you go with that pose again.
I don't like you.
I've decided you're the evil one! You're the evil one.
Well. You know to be honest. I can't stand all the politics around the major clubs
It feels like nothing but arguing about bub bud balloon bubble. It's in blah blah blah bit little bit blue
I'd rather make something, something
I personally enjoy and make something special out of it something,
and if it encourages others to get into literature, then I'm fulfilling that dream
Monika really is a great leader.
I see you holding hands under there.
Yuri also nods in agreement
Then I'm surprised there aren't more people in the club yet
It must be hard to start a new club
You could put it that way
not many people are very interested in putting out all the effort to start something brand new
Especially when it's something that doesn't grab your attention
like literature you have to work hard to convince people that you're both fun and worthwhile
But it makes school events like the festival that much more important
I'm confident that we can all really grow this club before we graduate right everyone?
Yeah!
Well do our best.
You know it!
Morp also part of this!
Morp also wanna be part of this! Morp also excited!
Such different girls all interested in the same goal
Morp also excited and interested and goal, but also Morp a boy
Oh Monika must have worked really hard just to find these three
Maybe that's why they're all so delighted by the idea of a new member joining
Though I still don't really know if I can keep up with their level of enthusiasm about literature
so Morp,
what things do you like to read?
Oh I read Warhammer like a lot of Warhammer 40k? I like that universe
It's very good me following it very closely.
Well. Uh considering a little I've read these past few years
I really doesn't have a good way of answering that
I like The Martian by Andy Weir
He's a good author
He's only wrote one book. Two now,  I need to read second book
Morp- Morp like manga
I mutter quietly to myself half joking
Natsuki's head suddenly perks up looks like she wanted to say something, but she keeps quiet
Not not much of a reader. I guess.
I like the pictures the pictures are good for Morp
Morp like pictures
Well that can change!
What am I saying? I spoke without thinking after seeing Yuri's sad smile
Anyway, what about you Yuri?
Well let's see
Yuri traces the rim of her teacup with her fingers
my favourites are usually novels that build deep and complex fantasy worlds
the level of creativity and craftsmanship behind them is amazing to me and
Telling your good stories such a foreign world is equally impressive
Yuri goes on clearly passionate about a reading
She seems so reserved and timid since the moment I walked in
but it's obvious by the way her eyes light up that she finds
Her comfort in the world of books not people
But you know I'd like a lot of things stories with deep psychological
Elements usually immerse me as well
Isn't it amazing how a writer can so deliberately take advantage of your own lack of imagination to complete, and throw you for a loop?
Anyway, I've been reading a lot of horror lately
Ah, there it is.
I read a- Morp read a horror book once once upon a time. It was good and scary
I desperately grasp something I can relate to at the minimal level
At this rate Yuri might as well be having a conversation with a rock
Morp likes to think Morp better than rock
I wouldn't have expected that Yuri for someone as gentle as you
I guess you could say that
I'm not very gentle after all
*Creepy laughter*
But if a story makes me think it takes me to another world
Then I really can't put it down
So real horror is often very successful at changing the way you look at the world if only for a brief moment
Oh, I hate horror really.
Oh, why is that?
Well, I just
Natsuki's eyes dart over to me for a split second
Nevermind.
That's right usually they like to write about cute things
Don't you Natsuki you're just a one big stereotype aren't you?
Wha-What!?
What gives you the right
You left a piece of scrap paper behind last Club meeting
It looked like you were working on a poem called-
Don't say it out loud, please
I'm super embarrassed and give that back
Fine fine
Your cupcake your poems everything about you is just as cute as you are
Sayori sidles up behind Natsuki and puts her hand on her shoulders
I'm not CUTE!
I'm into hardcore    ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Death metal I've got a scar!
I branded myself with a hot iron once.
I'm into BDSM
Don't judge me. I'm not cute ah
Natsuki you write your own poems?
Yeah, well, I guess sometimes. Why do you care?
I think that's impressive.
Why don't you share them sometime?
N-No!
No
Natsuki averts her eyes
You wouldn't like them or anything not like I wrote them for you anyway
Or nothing like that...
Ah,  not very confident writer yet?
I understand how Natsuki feels.
Sharing that level of writing takes more than just confidence.
The truest form of writing is writing one-
To oneself
you must be willing to open up to your readers
exposing your vulnerabilities and showing even the deepest reaches of your heart
Yuri! You're scaring me
It's very scary. I don't like that kind of talk there
Do you have writing experience too, Yuri?
Maybe if you share some of your work
she can setting an example and help Natsuki feel comfortable enough to share hers
*Pained sounds*
I guess it's the same for Yuri oh
Aw I wanted to read everyone's poems. Awn
We all sit in silence for a moment
Okay, okay.
Here's my lean.
I have an idea everyone.
huh? Natsuki-
I feel like decisions coming up hang on. Let's save again. I'm a spastic saver
Okay
Let's all go home and write poems of our own
Yee-hah, then next time we meet we'll all share them with one another that way everyone is even
*Less pained sounds*
Yeah! Let's do it! Plus now that we have a new member
I think it will help us all get a little more comfortable with each other and strengthen the bond of the club
Isn't that right Morp
Monika smiles warmly at me once again
Hold on
There's still one problem
*Confused sound* What's that?
now that we're back to the original topic of me joining the club
I bluntly come forth with what's been on my mind the entire time.
*Inhale*
I never said I would join this club
music cut
Sayori must have convinced me to stop by
But I never made any decision
music sudden slam cut
I still have other clubs
*Failed word attempts* clubs to look at
and of them lose my train of thought oh all four girls stare back at me with?
dejected eyes
But
I'm sorry I thought
Hmph.
*Laughs*
Morp
*Laughs again XD*
Like that's just her sound effects she makes when she's sad just morp morp morp MORP
you you all I'm
defenseless against these girls
How am I supposed to make it clear had a decision when it's like this?
That is if writing poems is the price I needed pay in order to spend every day with these beautiful girls
Right
okay, I've decided then
I'll join the literature club and seal my fate to certain doom
huh one by one the girls lights *hng* eyes light up
Yes, I'm so happy!
Sayori wraps her arms around me jumping up and down
Hey!
You really did scare me for a moment.
If you really just came for the cupcakes. I would be super pissed
Then- there's my lean, then that makes it official
huh alright welcome to the literature Club,
huh, thanks
I guess okay everyone. I think with that we can officially end today's meeting on a good note
It was about to be a terrible note and I would have had to murder some people
but okay everyone remember tonight's assignment
Write a poem to bring to the next meeting so we can all share
Monika looks over at me once more more
Morp, I look forward to seeing how you express yourself.
Oh, I'm gonna suppress Morp self so good
*Laughter or maybe choking*
Sorry severe spina bifida oh, yeah
Yeah, can I really impress the class star Monika with my mediocre writing skills?
I already feel the anxiety welling up inside me
among other emotions
Meanwhile the girls continue to chitchat as Yuri and Natsuki clean up their food.
Hey Morp since we're already here
Do you want to walk home together?
That's right Sayori
And I never walk home together anymore because she's always stayed school after the after school for clubs.
Sure might as well, I guess
Yahoo... Yahoo
and with that the two of us depart the club room and make our way back home the whole way my mind wanders back and
forth between the four girls Sayori
Natsuki
Yuri
and, of course, Monika
Will I really be happy spending every day after school in literature club perhaps?
I'll have a chance to glow closer to one of these girls
All right, I'll just need to make the most of my circumstances,
and I'm sure good fortune will find me
I guess that starts with writing our poem tonight.
Oh boy. I can't wait
gonna save some bads about to happen. I can tell
It's time to write a poem pick words you think your favorite club member will like
Something good might happen with whoever likes your poem the most
Oh ho ho oh ho ho ho
Oh boy oh boy. Oh boy, okay, all right, okay? All right, okay? All right? Oh?
BOOOOOOOOPPP
Boop
Wait no oh wait no Boop sticky damn it
uhhhhhhhhh
Fear fear
uhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
Agonizing
with some um
parfait
Oh Bob
*Muttering in dead langues*
DestINY
*Muttering*
Flee
*Mutter*
Nightgown!
Covet
um Incongruent
*Mumble*
i like spinning!
nibble
Mum mum hop
Explode
*Mumbling, just assume he's mumbling*
Frightening
FESTER
Uncanny
Kawaii~~~~~~~
Tenacious! I love my mum
Mum
vivacious
indeed ah
Hi, agian Morp!
Did I do good?
I made a poem it makes no goddamn. Sense someone write down my poem in the comments blow
It's so good. Glad to see you didn't run away on us
*Laughter*
Okay now don't worry. This might be a little strange for me, but at least keep my word well
I'm back at literature club that was the last to come in so everybody else is already hanging out
Thanks for keeping your promise Morp
I hope this isn't too overwhelming of a commitment for you
Making you dive headfirst into literature when you're not accustomed to it
Well come on like he deserves any slack
Sayori told me you didn't even want to join any clubs this year
That's not true and last year, too. I don't know if you plan to go just come here and hang out
Or what but if you don't take us seriously, then you won't see the end of it.
That's that's that's threatening
Okay, okay. Hi Monika
Natsuki. You certainly have a big mouth for someone who keeps her manga collection in the club room
*Le gasp*
*Blubbering*
Natsuki finds herself stuck between saying ma- Monica and manga
manga is literature
Swiftly defeated Natsuki plops back into her seat.
Don't worry guys Morp always gives it his best as long as he's having fun
Well lets all show him a good time I guess ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
He helps me with busy work without even me even asking
like cooking cleaning my room
Helping me bathe
How dependable
Ah yes, yes, I am that adjective
dependable amongst
excruciating and vivacious
Sayori that's because your room is so messy it's distracting
and you always- almost set your house on fire once
is that so *Nervous chuckle*
Well, you know live and learn and then get loves
you two are really good friends aren't you I might be a little jealous oh?
Well Yuri. Don't don't worry. Don't worry
There's more than one way to skin a cat
if ya kno- *mumble* ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Nevermind
how come you and Morp can become good friends too
um?
Oh, I don't know about that Sayori
Uh-huh Oh as usual, Sayori seems oblivious to the weird situation
She just put me into
Oh Yuri. Even brought you something today. You know
wait Sayori!
Yeah? Me? Morp? for Morp?
Ah not really
don't be shy come on
It's really nothing.
What is it?
Nevermind Sayori made it sound like a big deal when it's really not
Oh, you silly Billy.
What do I do?
I'm sorry Yuri?
I wasn't thinking I guess that means it's up to me to rescue this situation.
Hey, don't worry about it
Nailed IT
Solved it
first of all I wasn't expecting anything in the first place second of all anything you give me I'd immediately reject
Just because I'm that kind of person so any nice gesture from you is a pleasant surprise. It'll make me happy no matter
What because I'm at such a low level of happiness that anything's up from here.
Is that so
Yeah
I want to make it a big deal if you don't want it to be no matter how shitty your present is
Alright, well here
Yuri reaches into her bag and pulls out a book
I didn't want you to feel left out so I picked out a book. I thought you might enjoy
It's a short read, so it'll keep it should keep your attention. Even if you don't usually read and we could you know?
discuss it if you wanted
oh
This is how was this girl accidentally being so cute? Ha?
ha hee
Wowie wowie ok
alright. She even picked out a book she thinks I'll like despite me not reading much
Yuri, Thank you
I'll definitely read this maybe I
Enthusiastically take a book I'd be more excited about this, but I already promised
I wouldn't be whew well you can read it at your own pace. I look forward to hearing what you think?
Now that everyone settled in I expect Monika to kick off some scheduled activities for the club
But that doesn't seem to be the case
Sayori and Monika are having a cheery conversation in the corner
Yuris face is already buried in a book
I can't help but notice her intense expression like she was waiting for this chance
Meanwhile Natsuki is rummaging around a closet oh
Great, I'm really curious to talk to Yuri a little bit more at the same time
I would feel bad for distracting her from reading as a choice coming up
Where's the goddamned choices happening here?
I catch a glimpse of the cover of her book this looks like the same book that she lent to me
more than that she seems to be on the first few pages ah
Crap I think she noticed me looking at her she speaks another glance at me, and her eyes meet for a split second
It's a fate. Are we about to sing?
But that only makes her hide her face deeper in the book
Sorry, I was just spacing out your beautiful face. I mutter this sensing. I made her uncomfortable oh
It's fine if I was focused then I probably wouldn't have noticed in the first place your beautiful eyes
But I'm just rereading a bit of his so
that's the book you gave me right?
mm-hmm
I wanted to reread some stuff of it, so it was fresh in my mind for when we
discuss it
disscuss it
Not for any particular reason just curious. How come you have two copies of the same book?
Ah well when I stopped the bookstore yesterday. That's not what I meant
I mean, I just happened to buy two of them
I see
there's something fairly obvious here that Yuri isn't telling me, but I decided to let it go
I'll definitely start reading it soon
I'm glad to hear once it starts to pick up you might have a hard time putting it down
It's very engaging and relatable story about death
Is that so what's it about anyway?
Well death yes
Yuri closes the book and scans her eyes over the back the book is titled portrait of Markov
There's an ominous looking eye symbol on the front cover alright
Just want to make sure I don't actually get anything away basically
It's about this girl in high school it moves in with their long-lost younger sister
But as soon as she does her life gets really strange
She gets targeted by these people who escaped from a human experiment prison and while her life is in danger
She needs to desperately choose who to trust no matter what she does she ends up destroying most of her relationships and her life starts
To fall apart
that's kind of its kind of dark isn't it
Yuri made it sound like it was gonna be a nice story
So that dark turn came out of nowhere
Haha, Yuri gently giggles all of a sudden.
Are you not a fan of that sort of thing Morp?
No it's not that! Morp- Morp
Definitely fan of that sort of thing I mean I can definitely enjoy these kinds of stories still don't worry
I hope so
yeah, I totally forgot the Yuri's into those things
She's so shy, reclusive on the outside, but her mind seems so completely different. It's just those kind of stories
They challenge you to look at life from a strange new perspective when horrible things happen
Not just because someone wants to be evil
But because they have their own goals and their own philosophy that they believe in then suddenly when you thought you related to the protagonist
They're made out to be the naive one for letting the one-sided morals interfere with the villains plans. I'm
I'm rambling aren't I?
Not again. I'm sorry.
Hey don't apologize
Scary I'm scared out of my wits I peed my pants, but it's okay. Hey. I have lost interest or anything in you
Well, I guess it's alright then
But I feel like I should let you know that I have this problem
When I let things like books and writing fill my thoughts I kind of forget to pay attention to other people so
I'm sorry if I end up saying something strange
And please stop me if I start talking too much. That's
Impossible, I really don't think you need to worry. No one's talking to me in a long time
so welcome now this means you're passionate about reading the least I can do is listen so literature club after all
ah
Well, that's well. That's true in fact. I might as well get started reading it after all you don't have to
What are you saying just a moment ago? You said you were looking forward to it? Oh?
Let me just get the book. I quickly retrieve the book that I had put in my bag alright
it's fine if I sit here right
I slip into the seat next to Yuri's
ah
Yeah, are you sure you seem a little apprehensive?
That's I'm sorry. It's just the love in my heart
It's not that I don't want you to it's just something. I'm not very used to
That is reading in company with someone I see well
Just tell me if I end up distracting you or anything with my heavy breathing
I've got asthma as you know I like to wheeze when I'm really into a story
Alright, I open the book and start the prologue. I soon understand what Yuri meant by reading in company
It's as if I can feel her presence over my shoulder as a read
It's not a particularly bad thing maybe a little distracting, but the feeling is somewhat comforting Yuri's in the corner of my eye
I realized that she's not actually looking at her own book glanced over looks like she's reading from my book instead
So-Sorry I was just
Yuri, you really apologized a lot, don't you hey why don't you stop that I do they don't really mean to
Sorry, I mean
Ahaha aha
Here this should work right I slide my desk until it's up against Yuri's
And then hold my book more between the two of them ah I suppose so.
Man. This is the most romantic book reading
I've ever seen the tension in the air is palpable Yuri timidly closes her own copy once we lean
Once we each lean in a little bit our shoulders are almost touching. Oh
Oh!
Scandalous if ever I heard a scandalous thing
It feels like my left arm is in the way so instead I use my right hand to hold the book open
I guess that makes it kind of difficult to turn the page
Don't worry
I'll do it for you.
Ah there we are Yuri takes her left arm and holds the left side of the book between her thumb and forefinger ah
Ah
Romantic I do the same with my right arm on the right side of the book
The way I turn a page and Yuri slides it under a thumb after flips to her side
Oh...
But in holding it like this were huddled even closer than before
It's actually kind of distracting me.
This is ridiculous.
Hey! Hey Yuri get hey! Back off. What about personal bubble
Don't you understand it's as if I can feel the warmth of Yuri's face
And she's in the corner of my vision hey Morp don't play that shit Morp likes it cold when Morp reads!
Are you ready? Am I ready for what?
to turn the page ah sorry
I think I got a bit distracted for a second a glance over at Yuri's face again in her eyes meet
I don't know how I'll be able to keep up with her ah
That's okay. You're not as used to reading right? I don't mind being patient if it takes you a bit longer
It's probably the least I can do since you've been so patient with me
Yeah
Thanks, we continue reading you already. No longer asking me if I'm ready to turn the page instead
I just assumed that she finishes the page before me so I turn to my own volition
we continue the first chapter in silence even so turning each page almost feels like a
Intimate exchange
My thumb gently letting go of the pa- God is it getting hot in here is it just me all this thumb and paper
Action I can't hardly stand it the vapors letting it
Flutter over to her side as she catches it under her own thumb
Hey Yuri, this might be a silly thought
But you want to get married?
The main character kind of reminds me of you a little bit.
You think so?
How does she? Well, I guess she's more blunt in a lot of ways.
But she also second-guesses a lot of the things that she says and does just like you! Like she's afraid
she'll do something wrong
It's not like I can see into your head or anything, but they're kind of reminiscent of some of your mannerisms
I, I see okay
Well ow my pride, but also screw you you're a sack of shit
Okay, Yuri, remains silent for a moment
But Morp that's probably a terrible thing to have in common with her
Oh, that's so embarrassing that you think that wait wait
No, I realize how stupid that was of me to say I didn't mean it in a bad way or anything sorry
I really didn't know you were self-conscious about that horrible thing that you have
oh, you're self-conscious about that. Oh shit
You should be but Wow how how could I admit that I guess? I'm more meant that it's kind of cute ah turned it around
Instantly 180 all insults turn into compliments. What are you saying all of a sudden? I?
Okay, everyone huh, I think it's about time. We shared today's poems with each other we might not have enough time if we wait
too long oh
He Yuri exhales spared from finishing her thought is it alright Yuri. You look kind of down
I'm sorry if you haven't been able to look forward to this that's not it's fine
your releases her hand from the book causing it to close on top of my thumb
oh
My thumb alright, I guess I'll do some more reading tonight. What would you prefer if I only read it with you um...
I guess you can read around if you want. It's not like we have a
Closed reading. It's more of an open reading
Relationship hmm in that case. I'll read a little more tonight
It'll be more fun to read with you after it picks up a bit
You know that's good reasoning in that case feel free to finish the first two chapters in your own time all right
I stand up, okay
I'll make a mental note of where I left off in the book and then slip it back into my bag
Okay, by the way. Did you remember to write a poem last night?
Yup sure did it's a bunch of random words that came to my mind my relaxation ends
I can't believe I agreed to do something so embarrassing
I couldn't really find much inspiration since I've never really done this before
Well now that everybody's ready. Why don't you find someone to share with I can't wait
Sayori and Monika enthusiastically pull out their poems
Sayori's is on a wrinkled sheet of loose-leaf torn from a spiral notebook
On the other hand Monika wrote hers in a composition notebook
I can already see Monika's pristine handwriting it from where I sit
Natsuki and Yuri reluctantly complies well reaching into their bags. I do the same myself.
Okay! Alright we're gonna end this here
I don't know what's going on, and I don't know why but things seem to be perfectly normal
Which usually means that things aren't gonna be perfectly normal
So thank you everybody so much for watching if you want to write a poem of your very own
Write it down in the comments. I will be writing my very own poem in the description. I will... I'm... I don-
I can't promise it'll be good, but I'll write a poem. Yeah freaky
I'll write a poem doesn't have to be long write a poem in the comments Let's all share and check out each other's poems
I'll be reading through the comments and let me know you think so
Thank you everybody so much for watching and as always< I will see you in the next video!
Bye bye!!
(blushing Yuri dance party)